camilla
is in las vegas hi camila how are you
hi dave and chris it's a pleasure to
speak to you guys today
you too how can we help okay
well um my husband and i are um
going through a divorce and we own a
small business together and i'm
wondering
what formula to use to split up that
small business
i'm sorry how long you've been married
thank you
um we've been married 10 years what
happened
um he walked he
just walked out of the marriage
so who's been running the business tell
me how that works
uh he runs the business day to day i've
worked
in the business um throughout the years
but he's taken over all those
responsibilities
in the last six months
okay so what do you plan to do with your
life
um i'm not quite sure yet i'm working on
that
how long ago did he walk out um
a couple um let's see probably
like three months ago
how many kids you got three kids
what age um eight years old four years
old and
a year and a half
so i assume over this three months he's
begun paying child support during the
separation correct
um we've had our accounts together still
we so we've been working together out of
we have one account
and just um and he's living with his
parents so it doesn't have any extra
expenses
so you're just using the money with the
combined accounts to take care of the
family
yes okay
all right um do you all own anything
else
any money um we own our cars
and um and
we that's it yeah that's the only thing
that we have and we
don't have any money anymore there's no
retirement accounts
yeah we have um we both have retirement
accounts
like fifteen thousand dollars each
okay and um we our home
we have a little bit of equity and
probably like a hundred thousand dollars
worth of equity
and what's the home worth um
it's worth about three hundred thousand
dollars okay
and so you owe 200. yes
were you a stay-at-home mom or did you
work
outside of the home i was i was working
in
our business okay um but yeah but not
not a regular set time yeah it changed
and it changed
over the years that we had the business
um we've had it for five years
okay what is your attorney saying
um i don't know i haven't gotten their
advice about it yet
okay let me help you with this three
months after your husband walks out and
lives with his parents it's too late to
get an attorney
so you know i have one i just we've been
trying to mediate
mostly and not use attorneys
okay that's fine there's nothing wrong
with mediating but you need an attorney
to close and put a lid on this and so
you're not getting any legal advice at
all
i i am i guess i just don't know what
the right questions
to ask are well the legal advice says
the legal advice says that you're going
to get a
pile of child support from him for three
little kids
and the legal advice then should say
that you're getting half of
everything else at least yeah okay
yeah um so here are what's what is the
net profit on the business in a year
net profit taxable income what did you
all pay
taxes on last year last year it was
forty thousand dollars
okay all right well the business is
probably worth
uh between if that's an exact figure
it's worth
somewhere around four times that so
around 160.
okay and so if you sold the house
and you took his retirement account and
you got the equity out of the house and
he got the business that's probably
not a bad trade okay
so you had 30 000 in retirement at that
point you got a hundred thousand
um and you get your car you get the most
expensive car of the two
uh you're getting pretty close to half
of the assets at that point
okay and he has the business free and
clear of you
and then he can run it and pay child
support and maybe alimony depending on
what you come up with
yeah okay um
in i also wanted to mention that in the
beginning of 2019
we bought out a partner that we had for
36 that had 30 percent
we bought them out for 90 000.
you overpaid yeah that's what i'm
guessing yeah yeah so and you pay cash
for that
uh no we took out a second loan on our
homes to do that
okay has that been paid off
um we've been paying it down but no it's
not paid off yet
so that's part of the equity in the home
you're getting in my scenario so that is
an interesting part of the equation yeah
so what i'm trying to do is to get you
half of the assets and him end up with
the business because you don't want to
remain in the business from
the guy you're divorced from right you
don't want to trust him to give you
accurate numbers on the p
l no yeah he's already lost me out of
all the accounts
right yeah and and and here's the deal
he doesn't want you to get an attorney
just because he's trying to get it done
as cheap as possible
yeah and he's trying to probably i think
you probably need legal accounts you do
you that's the only way you're going to
get a clarity
and it's going to be an equal and it's
going to be something that you get done
in the best interest of your children
not trying to pick a fight i'm just
trying to keep you from getting bullied
right yeah it's time to make the phone
call
young lady yeah i agree it is and uh
you walk them through what you've been
through uh and that they'll hear in your
voice i hear it the fear
and the nerves but you're gonna be okay
and here's the last part of the equation
and this is
going to add to your pain not take away
from it on the short term
but on the long term it's going to help
you unless you're going to land
a very very serious career very quickly
like eighty thousand dollar income or
above
you're not going to be able to stay in
this house yeah
we're playing i'm planning to sell it
and just rent something
cheaply okay good and then you've got to
get your career started and
start putting tools in your belt with
that money that you get
from the house i think you get the house
equity and the nicest car
and all the retirement accounts and then
maybe some more
okay and then he gets the business
that's because the business is probably
worth about four times forty
so somewhere but maybe five times so
somewhere between 160 and 200
is his portion and if you can get
everything else to add up to close to
that
you're getting pretty close or have him
you know give you 50 grand he goes to
the bank gets it i don't care
what he does at this point he's walking
off for my wife and three kids so i'm
not getting much use for him so um
ah man what a mess it is
um yeah i think the best pain came out
of the whole call though chris is what
you said that she needs an attorney
she does and not everybody that ends up
marriage is a horrible guy
no it's not me guy bashing so you stupid
people that send me that stuff i don't
guy bash
um every you know we don't know the
whole situation
but um we're hearing all we've got is
what she told us the facts
yeah the details so but but
yeah you're entitled to i think more
than it is being hinted that you're
going to get
that's my opinion in listening to it um
and sometimes that just requires
uh standing up and uh that's what chris
is saying so
get some legal counsel i would get the
house sold take all of that money i'd
take
one or two cars and take all the
retirement and maybe some out of the
business
if there's unless there's some other
money somewhere else but i tell you what
i also love the fact of you just being
straight up with her and letting her
know that that house can't stay
so she can emotionally go ahead she's
already done it though
yeah she was aware that's good that's a
good thing a lot of people try to hold
on to a house they can't afford after
divorce keep the kids
stable in the house all the stuff and it
bring it continues the nightmare yeah
it really shortens it
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show